dice are you serious about making
battlefield I'm asking myself that
question after well over a hundred hours
into the game maybe I should have asked
this question sooner second assault the
second DLC after China rising for
Battlefield 4 dropped last week months
after Xbox one the DLC is buggy to say
the least it's assignments are confusing
and there seems to be a general lack of
understanding of what the dedicated
community wants operation Metro 2014 for
example rehashes a map that like
operation locker isn't actually a fan
favorite so much as a means to grind a
loveless unlock tree second assault is a
mess in the first week of the dlc lo
player populations high ping servers
dropping out randomly sound bugs and no
one playing signature mode capture the
flag have made the experience fairly
miserable and I doubt you sold many
premium subscriptions as your early
price drop would also indicate let's not
forget the same type of price drop you
did in battlefield 3 that punished early
adopters and maybe turn them off to
buying premium again technically this
DLC has all kinds of problems vehicles
hover in midair after exploding
characters vanish from existence rather
than rag doll railing vaulting yes the
thing that was supposed to be fixed in
battlefield 3 is still here I got stuck
on ankle high obstacles stuck running
over the crest of hills sound dropped
out when they entered vehicles
architecture dropped in and out in the
killcam and that's just the
unintentional stuff the assignments and
second assault remind me of early
battlefield 4 advertisements the ones
that said I didn't know that could
happen in battlefield I see this little
tiny boats likely so basically I'm going
full speed
Oh boom I hit it everything blows I I
find into the boat and ceiling I didn't
even know that was possible the
dedicated community laughed at those
because they had a double meaning not
knowing you can do something in
battlefield is a statement of amazement
but also of frustration because the game
never explains itself very well the new
weapons you can unlock the AS VAL m60 e4
GOL magnum dao 12 and f 2000 are
fantastic weapons but in order to get
them assignments take a really fun game
and make it confusing and miserable
instructions for these assignments are
unclear to say the least in order to get
the doubt 12 for example you need a
shotgun ribbon and to raise and lower
the border gate on Caspian let's start
with the ludicrous idea that caspian
border is a shotgun map oh yes you have
to get that shotgun ribbon on Caspian
but for some reason your other 40
shotgun ribbons don't count but you
probably learned that by trial and error
because the description doesn't say in
one round speaking of frustration to get
the GOL magnum sniper rifle the
assignment requires you to climb up one
of two very specific towers on Caspian
or firestorm these towers are exposed to
the entire map and death is assured once
you get out in the open why would any
decent recon player expose themselves to
the map in that way in the first place
this assignment causes players to all
camp in one place when they should be
roving the map playing objectives then
after hours of trying players will
discover that you don't even need sniper
kills you can just walk up to the tower
and shoot people off of it with any
weapon it's frustration the emotion you
wanted players to experience let's talk
about the m60 also a favorite from bad
company 2 in order to earn this you need
to destroy five vehicles with a support
class on Oman the support class a class
not designed to destroy vehicles a class
that doesn't even get c4 until the last
unlock and why would you unlock a light
machine gun by destroying vehicles
something a light machine gun doesn't do
even remotely I never even got a crack
at the f2000 because Metro was excluded
from almost every playlist these type of
issues aren't excusable at launch much
less for months on which brings me back
to my original
question dice are you serious about
making battlefield this is a franchise
that I've poured hundreds of hours of my
life into but at this stage I'm not sure
if this relationship goes both ways
battlefield is a game that I want to be
great but that doesn't actually make it
so we'll see what happens when naval
strike drops in March but you're going
to have to do a lot better than this
you